aquí tenemos un polinomio y lo que me
interesa saber es cuál es el residuo
cuando divido este polinomio entre x
menos 2 queremos entonces saber cuál es
el residuo cuando dividimos este
polinomio entre x menos 2 y esto lo
puedes calcular si haces el proceso
largo de división algebraica te voy a
dar una ayuda es mucho más simple haces
menos cálculo si no usas tanto papel
si aplicas el problema del residuo para
polinomios supongo que ya lo conoces si
no puedes revisar los videos que ya
hemos hecho acerca del teorema del
residuo para polinomios muy bien ahora
hagámoslo juntos el teorema del residuo
para polinomios nos dice que cuando
tengo un polinomio cuando tengo un
polinomio px y lo divido entre x menos a
lo divido entre x menos a entonces
entonces el residuo es igual al
polinomio evaluado en ar el residuo es
igual ap de a p vea en este caso el
polinomio de x es este que tenemos aquí
y cuál es el valor de a a es igual a 2
pues se observa que aquí tenemos x menos
a vamos a marcarlo aquí es igual a 2 así
es que en este caso para encontrar el
residuo tenemos que evaluar
pd2 hagamos eso así es que el residuo en
este caso va a ser igual a
p
d
dos dedos y esto es igual a lo voy a
hacer todo en magenta esto es igual a
menos 3 por 8 menos 4 x 4 - 4x4 más 20
menos 7 y esto es igual a menos 24 menos
16 más 20
-7 y esto es igual
veamos menos 24 menos 16 es menos 40 voy
a hacerlo paso a paso esto de aquí es
igual a menos 40 no lo va a ser mejor
mentalmente menos 24 menos 16 es menos
40 20 es menos 20 menos 7 esto es igual
a menos 27 y esto es fabuloso pues para
obtener este resultado sin usar el
teorema del residuo hubiéramos tenido
que hacer muchas operaciones algebraicas
calculando la división larga entre los
polinomios por supuesto que al hacer la
división larga hubiéramos obtenido el
cociente y demás pero no necesitamos el
cociente sólo requerimos el residuo si
hubiéramos hecho todo el proceso de la
división larga hubiéramos / p de equis
entre
x menos a aquí hubiéramos obtenido el
cociente digamos un polinomio q de x y
aquí después de haber hecho varias
operaciones algebraicas que quizá no
hubieran cabido el papel eventualmente
hubiéramos obtenido una expresión de
orden menor al que se tiene aquí tendría
que ser una constante pues esto es de
orden 1 así es que tiene que ser de
orden 0 aquí hubiera aparecido menos 27
pero lo que hicimos nosotros fue mucho
mucho más fácil no tuvimos que hacer
todo este proceso tan complicado espero
que hayas apreciado esto